[Música]
por segundo día consecutivo Rusia lanzó
bombardeos contra varias ciudades de
Ucrania en la que ya es la ofensiva
aérea más importante desde el inicio de
la guerra ante el g7 el presidente de
ucraniano por accidente proporcionarles
suficiente apoyo de defensa para detener
a Moscú
el gobierno francés intervendrá en la
huelga de los trabajadores de las
refinerías la primera ministra Elizabeth
anunció ante la asamblea nacional un
proceso de requisición el cual obliga a
los empleados a cumplir con sus
funciones un tercio de las estaciones de
servicio en el país galo no tienen
combustible pero tienen un alto grado de
desabastecimiento
ya hay fecha para la coronación del rey
de Inglaterra Carlos III y la reina
consorte y Camila el 6 de mayo del
próximo año en la abadía de Westminster
será el primer acto de este tipo en
Reino Unido en 70 años tenemos informe
desde Londres
actualizamos la información aquí en la
pantalla de France 24 Gracias por
continuar con nosotros Yo soy Juan
pupiales los ataques de rusos golpearon
de nuevo Este martes a varias ciudades
ucranianas Un día después de que Moscú
lanzara una de las peores ofensivas
aéreas de los últimos meses el kremlin
asegura que su blanco es la
infraestructura energética y militar de
ucraniano la Oficina de derechos humanos
de Naciones Unidas expresó su
preocupación porque Rusia esté apuntando
a objetivos civiles en la jornada de
ayer 19 personas perdieron la vida más
en el siguiente informe
por segundo día consecutivo los
ucranianos despertaron con el sonido de
sirenas y nuevos bombardeos misiles
golpearon el pueblo suroriental de
zaporilla a la mañana de este martes
hubo dos explosiones luego una tercera
fue fuerte las cosas volaban por allá
corría el pasillo los niños lloraban mi
nieto lloraba
Mientras tanto las autoridades afirmaban
que las instalaciones centrales energía
de Ucrania habían sufrido serios daños
parte de la ciudad del VIP quedó sin
electricidad luego de los bombardeos el
martes el ministro de defensa de Rusia
confirmó los ataques que también
golpearon las ciudades eso lo vianx y ni
Pro
las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa continuaron hoy un masivo ataque
aéreo y marítimo con armas de precisión
de largo alcance contra el control
militar ucraniano e instalaciones del
sistema energético
todo esto después de que muscular más de
80 misiles en ciudades por todo Ucrania
incluyendo la capital el día lunes la
Oficina de derechos humanos en Naciones
Unidas expresó preocupaciones de que los
ataques de Rusia estén dirigidos a
infraestructura civil vital y que estos
Podrían haber violado las leyes de la
guerra debemos señalar esta
intencionalidad ataques dirigidos contra
civiles y objetivos civiles Eso
significa objetivos que no son militares
equivalente a un crimen de guerra
el bombardeo de Moscú lleguen aparente
retaliación una explosión de un puente
clave que une a Rusia con la anexionada
Península de crimea el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin culpó Ucrania y advirtió
de severas respuestas a futuros ataques
ante la ofensiva rusa hoy martes se
llevó a cabo una Cumbre extraordinaria
del g7 en la que este grupo de países
condenó lo que calificó como una
escalada deliberada por parte de Moscú
las potencias occidentales emitieron un
comunicado en el que insisten en que el
uso de armas nucleares químicas o
biológicas tendría graves consecuencias
dicen también que mantienen el
compromiso de seguir aportando ayuda a
Ucrania precisamente eso fue algo que
agradeció el presidente ucraniano bolo
de mercelenski quien también solicitó
soporte para crear un escudo aéreo para
defender a su país escuchemos
les agradezco toda la ayuda que han
brindado es grande es significativa pero
el líder ruso que ahora se encuentra en
la etapa final de su reinado todavía
tiene espacio para una mayor escalada
esta posibilidad es una amenaza para
todos nosotros
Ucrania sigue denunciando la aparición
de masivas de la aparición masiva de
fuerzas comunes en medio de la guerra la
noticia la dio fiscal general quien dio
a conocer estos hallazgos en un pueblo
recuperado en la región de donesk se
trata de la localidad de liman en donde
se sumaron al menos 55 cuerpos el mes
pasado de las autoridades subcranianas
aseguraron haber exhumado los cuerpos de
436 personas en Misión otra ciudad
recientemente liberada en medio de la
actual contra ofensiva de Ucrania
ya se encontraron 55 cuerpos pero el
trabajo continúa estos cuerpos son
civiles locales y nuestros Defensores
militares de las fuerzas armadas las
causas de las muertes serán determinadas
por peritos médicos judiciales
resultados preliminares la causa de la
muerte lesiones por explosivos y
proyectiles lesiones por bala tampoco
excluimos la tortura especialmente entre
las víctimas civiles
la masacre de bucha constituye uno de
los primeros crímenes de guerra de Rusia
en Ucrania según Naciones Unidas han
pasado más de seis meses de esta matanza
y los supervivientes luchan por
sobreponerse y poder seguir adelante con
sus vidas nuestros corresponsales y
hotel y Diego Ibarra visitaron la zona
el betlán ha sacado a pasear a su hijo
Vladimir al cementerio habla de mí le
cuesta entender la muerte y para
evitarle más dolor le ha contado que su
padre está dormido el 4 de marzo fue
alcanzado por una bala mortal de un
francotirador ruso cuando salió a
comprar pañales para hablar
Aquí estaba atendido mi marido no pude
recoger el cadáver tuvimos que irnos
porque temía por Vladimir y tuve que
dejarle aquí solo el cuerpo del marido
desvelana y otros 14 civiles
permanecieron esta calle de bucha por un
mesentero ahora sus vecinos la han
renombrado el callejón de la muerte
tetania nos muestra las imágenes de
soldados rusos sacando a civiles de sus
casas Que consiguió grabar con su móvil
8 personas fueron ejecutadas detrás del
patio trasero de su vivienda
no es justo que tantas mujeres se quedan
sin marido que los niños se quedan sin
padre Solo quiero que los que cometieron
estos crímenes sean castigados
no es fácil lidiar con el dolor de la
muerte sobre todo si ha sido en
circunstancias trágicas
hemos trabajado juntos toda la vida a él
lo tomaron cautivo los rusos y a mí me
dejaron libre No superen nada más de él
Hasta que vi su tumba pero más difícil
es sobreponerse a la desaparición de un
ser querido Alexandra Lleva más de seis
meses sin saber nada de su padre Sigue
esperando cada día la llamada los
servicios para buscar los desaparecidos
durante la Guerra habiendo solo mi padre
nos pidió que nos fuéramos de aquí me
dijo este lugar va a ser horrible yo me
quedaré el 24 de marzo leí en facebook
que había desaparecido lo llamé varias
veces pero su teléfono estaba apagado
desde ese día aparecen mis sueños para
hablarme
las matanzas y desapariciones de cientos
de civiles en bucha y recientemente
emisión han causado profundas heridas
psicológicas entre la población Y si no
hay justicia si no hay rendición de
cuentas el trauma perseguirá a las
nuevas generaciones
el gobierno francés decidió intervenir
en la huelga de las refinerías de total
energias y Epson móvil que han causado
escasez de combustible en al menos una
tercera parte de las estaciones de
servicio afectando a millones de
franceses La idea es requerir al
personal para que las empresas vuelvan a
funcionar algo que va en contra de la
postura de la mayoría de los sindicatos
Andrés granadillo con la información
tras más de dos semanas de huelga y una
crisis en el suministro de combustibles
el gobierno decidió intervenir así lo
hizo saber durante una sesión de la
asamblea la primera ministra Elizabeth
desde
proposición las propuestas sobre la mesa
por la empresa exo móvil no son mínimas
son significativas por eso he pedido a
los perfectos como permite la ley que
hagan una requisición del personal
necesario para el funcionamiento de los
depósitos de la empresa un funcionario
con esta medida El Ejecutivo obliga a
los trabajadores de las refinerías de
eso Epson móvil y total energis a volver
a sus funciones y de esta forma mitigar
el impacto sobre el suministro de
combustibles en el país y es que en las
calles las filas para poder tanquear los
vehículos son interminables Pero los
sindicatos que exigen una mejora
salarial ante las ganancias
extraordinarias de las empresas
persisten en sus peticiones
compartimos por supuesto el sufrimiento
de todos los individuos y como todos
entendemos que uno necesita un vehículo
para ir al trabajo para el ocio o
incluso simplemente para las citas
médicas Pero entonces el personal que
hoy ejerce su derecho a la huelga no
está aquí para interrumpir solo está
aquí para mostrar su descontento para
defender la necesidad real de poder
vivir decentemente con sus trabajos
la huelga obligado a las empresas a
desconectar más del 60% de la capacidad
Nacional de refinado y a bloquear la
distribución de los depósitos de
combustible en un momento de escasez
mundial de derivados del petróleo
el 6 de mayo de 2023 ese día hacia la
Coronado del nuevo rey de Inglaterra
Carlos III y su esposa la reina consorte
y Camila así lo anunció Este martes el
Palacio de buckingham los detalles sobre
este evento formal que Sella el cambio
en el trono los tiene desde Londres en
nuestra corresponsal Luisa Pulido quien
previamente nos envió el siguiente
informe
el Rey Carlos III será el primer monarca
en la historia británica de edad
avanzada en ser Coronado lo será a los
74 años la ceremonia se realizará en la
tradicional abadía de Westminster en el
centro de Londres donde se ha realizado
todas las coronaciones en los últimos
900 años y está promete ser un reflejo
de una sociedad mucho más moderna más
corta y que será transmitida en vivo y
en directo por la televisión de todo el
mundo y a través de las redes sociales
la de la Reina Isabel la última de la
que se tiene
récord por supuesto fue hace 69 años
esta duró tres horas y además tuvo
altísimos costos y muchos lujos lo que
se cree también es que la del Rey Carlos
III será un reflejo justamente por la
situación económica de crisis que
atraviesa el país Carlos tercero será
Coronado junto con su esposa
consorte de Camila Parker bowls Aunque
todavía no se conocen todos los detalles
de esta ceremonia
en noticias económicas hacia el fondo
monetario internacional empeoró su
previsión de crecimiento para la
economía mundial esto para el próximo
año al 12,7% desde el 2,9% anterior y
advirtió que lo peor está por venir a
referirse a que el mundo podría sufrir
Una recesión severa a niveles novios
desde el inicio de la pandemia de Kobe
19 la agencia crediticia de 190 países
citó una larga lista de amenazas que
incluyen la guerra en Ucrania las
presiones inflacionarias crónicas las
altas tasas de interés y las
consecuencias persistentes de la
pandemia mundial agregó que las tres
economías más grandes Estados Unidos
China y la zona Euro seguirán estancadas
la desaceleración de 2023 será amplia y
se espera que los países que representan
un tercio de la economía mundial se
contraigan este año o el próximo las
tres economías más grandes Estados
Unidos China y la zona del euro
continuarán estancadas en resumen lo
peor está todavía por venir y para
muchas personas 2023 se sentirá como una
recesión
la crisis socioeconómica que golpea
Haití amenaza con salirse de control el
descontento ante la situación del país
crece y diariamente y manifestaciones
que exigen la renuncia del Primer
Ministro ayer lunes enfrentamientos
entre la policía y manifestantes en
Puerto Príncipe se cobraron la vida de
una persona abre el coche nos amplía
en Haití la frustración contra el
gobierno crece este lunes las protestas
dejaron un muerto en enfrentamientos con
la policía los manifestantes lanzaron
piedras de las autoridades que
respondieron con gases lacrimógenos
desde que el gobierno anunció la subida
del precio del combustible el 11 de
septiembre ahí sí se ha visto afectada
por manifestaciones y saqueos el
desempleo el alto costo de vida la
inseguridad es por todas estas razones
por las que estoy en la calle no a la
ocupación
la intervención de fuerzas
internacionales para hacer frente a la
violencia y el secretario general de la
ONU Antonio Gutiérrez llamó este domingo
a intervenir con rapidez pero la
población rechaza la posible
intervención
estoy en la calle porque oigo que los
blancos van a pisotear el suelo del
padre de salim porque quieren pisotear a
la lucha de desalín como hicieron en
la población denuncia la inacción del
gobierno respecto a la violencia entre
criminales una situación que se degradó
en los últimos meses según homenajes
locales las mujeres sufren
particularmente de la crisis de
seguridad ya que su cuerpo está usado
como arma de guerra además el país sufre
un repunte en los casos de cólera más de
100 personas están siendo tratadas en
este Centro Médico de las Islas un
Barrio Pobre de la capital
el domingo pasado cuando me desperté vi
a mi hijo vomitando y con diarrea
[Música]
lo llevé a un centro cercano a mi casa
pero no había ningún médico que lo
atendiera
fue la gente de médicos Sin fronteras la
que nos llevó a este centro para que le
dieran los cuidados necesarios la
escasez de combustible y agua potable
así como la inseguridad dificultan aún
más el acceso a la asistencia sanitaria
en el país
terminamos con buenas noticias porque la
agencia espacial estadounidense NASA
confirmó el éxito de su misión con la
que cambiaron la órbita de un asteroide
en una prueba que hace parte de una
estrategia para salvar al planeta de una
posible amenaza real la Navidad chocó
contra el asteroide timorfos a 11
millones de kilómetros de la tierra y
logró reducir su órbita explicó la Nasa
en una rueda de prensa Esto ocurrió el
pasado 26 de septiembre pero apenas
hasta ahora la agencia pudo comprobar la
efectividad de esta maniobra con lo que
se convierte oficialmente en la primera
vez que el ser humano ha conseguido el
movimiento deliberado de un cuerpo
Celeste
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
quédense en francés 24
[Música]